The following line passes
through the point 5 comma 8,
and the equation of the line
is y is equal to 17/13x plus b.
What is the value of
the y-intercept b?
So we know that this
point, this x and y value
must satisfy this
equation, so we
know that when x is equal
to 5, y is equal to 8.
So we can say-- so when x is
equal to 5, y is equal to 8.
So we can say 8 must be equal
to 17/13 times x times 5 plus b,
and then we can solve for b.
So if we simplify
this a little bit,
we get 8 is equal to--
let's see, 5 times 17 is 50,
plus 35 is 85-- is 85/13 plus b.
Then to solve for b, we just
subtract 85/13 from both sides.
So we have 8 minus 85/13.
85/13 Is equal to b.
And now we just have to
subtract these two numbers.
So 8 is the same
thing as-- let's see.
80 plus 24 is 104,
so it is 104/13--
this is the same thing
as 8-- minus 85/13,
which is going to
be-- let's see.
This is 19/13.
Is that right?
Yes, if this was 105,
then it would be 20/13.
So this is 19/13, so it's equal
to 19/13, which is equal to b.
So the equation of this
line is going to be y
is equal to 17/13x plus 19/13.